HYPERBOLE MACHINE SELF COMBUST.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
AS THE DEMOCRATS RUSH TO THE
CREDIT CARD DEMOCRACY, G.O.P.
LEADERS ARE FIGHTING BACK.
KEVIN McCARTHY SENT HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI A LETTER
DEMANDING SHE AND MAKE
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRIES UNTIL
"EQUITABLE RULES AND PROCEDURES
ARE PUT IN PLACE."
OUR NEXT GUEST ALSO FILED AN
AMICUS BRIEF IN FEDERAL COURTS
TODAY CONTESTING THE LEGALITY OF
THE ENTIRE INCONGRUITY.
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS ARGUING
THE HOUSE MUST VOTE BEFORE THE
PROCESS BEGINS, WHICH DID NOT
HAPPEN HERE.
CAN STAR RATED THAT ISSUE LAST
NIGHT.
JOINING ME NOW, CONGRESSMAN DOUG
COLLINS, RANKING MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, HOW CAN THE
DEMOCRATS RUN IN    IN A CREDIBE
INVESTIGATION WITHOUT THE
PUBLICANS INVOLVED?
>> THEY CAN'T, LAURA.
I'VE BEEN NINE MONTHS WITH THIS,
I BEEN WATCHING JERRY NADLER AND
HIS HAPPY BAD MAJORITY RUN
ROUGHSHOD OVER RULES, THEY WANT
ONE THING AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THEY WANT TO DO IT SINCE
2016.
THAT'S WHY -- AT THE END OF THE
DAY, PEOPLE UNDERSTAND FAIRNESS.
PEOPLE MAY DISAGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT, MAY NOT LIKE
PRESIDENT, BUT WHEN YOU HAVE THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE WHO REFUSES
TO BRING AN INQUIRY TO THE
FLOOR, WHY DOES THAT MATTER?
WHY DOES THAT
IF THEY MADE HER DEMOCRATS VOTE
FOR THE INQUIRY AND THEY STARTED
A NEW INQUIRY, WE IN THE
MINORITY HAVE A RIGHT.
MY SELF WOULD HAVE SUBPOENA
POWER IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
JUST LIKE CHAIRMAN NADLER WOULD.
THE CHAIRMAN COULD WEIGH IN TO
SAY THAT I SHOULD BE RECUSED.
ISN'T THAT A UNIQUE CONCEPT?
IN AMERICA, WE BELIEVE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE DUE PROCESS RIGHTS.
BUT THIS SPEAKER IS RUNNING
ROUGHSHOD OVER THE HOUSE AND
IT'S GOT TO STOP.
THIS IS A TRAVESTY AND IT'S
AFFECTING THE INSTITUTION OF THE
HOUSE.
>> Laura: IT'S AFFECTING HOW
PEOPLE LAID OUT IN THE ANGLE,
CONGRESSMAN, HOW PEOPLE VIEW OUR
DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC, PEOPLE VIEW
THE PRESS, HOW PEOPLE VIEW THE
ENTIRE CONCEPT OF FAIRNESS.
THE PRESIDENT BEING HAMSTRUNG IN
HIS ABILITY TO CONDUCT FOREIGN
POLICY.
I'M SORRY, BUT THAT CHINA,
NORTH KOREA, THE WAY THEY LOOK
AT THIS -- THEY DON'T CARE ONE
WHIT ABOUT HOW THIS AFFECTS OUR
ECONOMY OR ANYTHING ELSE.
IT'S ABOUT TEARING DOWN THIS
PRESIDENT, RIPPING THEM OUT OF
OFFICE BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
I'VE GOT TO ASK YOU.
NANCY PELOSI GAVE AN INTERVIEW
ON ABC WHERE I THINK SHE
REVEALED UNWITTINGLY WHAT'S
REALLY GOING ON.
WATCH.
>> THE REAL THING IS
DONALD TRUMP WOULD DONALD TRUMP
DO IRREPARABLE DAMAGE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE SOME SERIOUS REPAIR AND
HEALING FOR WHAT HE'S DONE SO
FAR.
I'M NOT SURE TWO TERMS, IT MIGHT
BE IRREPARABLE.
>> THAT'S IT.
>> Laura: WE CAN'T RISK THE
PEOPLE VOTING FOR PEACE AND
PROSPERITY, IT'S AMAZING TO ME.
>> NANCY PELOSI HAS LITTLE FAITH
IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF SHE BELIEVES THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY CANDIDATES FOR PRESIDENT
WERE ACTUALLY ON THE RIGHT
TRACK, ACTUALLY SHARING THE
RIGHT MESSAGE, WHY IS SHE SELLS
COMFORTABLE
SO SKEPTICAL OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE VOTING FOR THE RIGHT IDE?
SHE KNOWS DONALD TRUMP IS
CONNECTING WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, SHE DID IT IN 2016, WE
ARE GOING TO SEE IT AGAIN NEXT
YEAR, AND WHAT SHE'S WILLING TO
DO IS TO OVERTURN THE NEXT
ELECTION BECAUSE SHE IS SCARED.
THIS IS HER SECOND TIME AROUND
AS SPEAKER.
WHAT DID WE GET THE FIRST TIME?
WE GOT OBAMACARE, GOT ALL KINDS
OF THINGS WE ARE NOW HAVING TO
DIG OUT OF.
>> Laura: SHOVEL READY.
IT'S ALL SHOVEL READY.
>> SHOVEL READY.
WHAT SHOVEL READY IS WHAT SHE'S
SPREADING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH THIS
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
THAT'S SHOVEL READY BECAUSE IT'S
NOT ANYTHING CLOSE -- SHE'S
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
THAT'S WHY THE AMICUS BRIEF WAS
FILED.
IF SHE WANTED THIS INFORMATION,
SHE KNEW SHE HAD TO.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN,
FOX NEWS JUST CONFIRMED THE
PRESIDENT WILL SEND PELOSI A
LETTER TOMORROW THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS GOING TO IGNORE
DEMOCRAT DEMANDS UNTIL THE HOUSE
FORMALLY APPROVED IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
HE'S DARING HER TO HOLD
IMPEACHMENT VOTE.
GOOD MOVE?
>> I THINK WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE -- DO YOU KNOW WHO
IS SCARED RIGHT NOW?
ABOUT 30-40  40 DEMOCRATS IN THE
SEATS TRUMP WON.
YOU RECOGNIZE YOUR PUTTING IN
JEOPARDY OF THE HOUSE MAJORITY
THAT YOU WON LAST YEAR ON A
PLATFORM OF YOU ARE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
YOU'RE GOING TO DO
INFRASTRUCTURE, PRESCRIPTION
DRUG CRISIS.
YOU'VE DONE NONE OF THAT EXCEPT
ATTACKED THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM THAT WE ARE
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU WANT TO DO IT PROPERLY,
BY THE BOOK, DO THAT.
BUT SPEAKER PELOSI, CHAIRMAN
NADLER, CHAIRMAN SCHIFF, HE
CAN'T SPELL TRUTH MUCH LESS TELL
IT.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WE ARE
SEEING RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE
DESTROYING THE INSTITUTION OF
THE HOUSE AND EVERYBODY,
REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS,
INDEPENDENCE OUGHT TO BE
AGGRIEVED BY THAT.
>> Laura: I'VE GOT TO TELL